in this video we'll be talking about
anany anany is a neural tube defect
where the entire brain of the baby fails
to
form so our brain develops from a sheet
of cells known as the
neuroectoderm we are looking at this
neural tube formation in a uh dorsal
View and a crosssectional view you can
see the yellow layer would eventually be
folded and it will give the blueprint of
the nervous
system here you can see a neural groove
or a dimple has formed initially
eventually this gets deeper and deeper
and eventually rolls into a tube and
this is known as neural tube
closing this event of neural tube
closure is really important to for
formation of the nervous
system now in human the nervous the the
neural tube closure in the cranial end
that means towards the head of the
embryo happens at the Daye
24 neural plate begins to form at day 22
eventually the neurop poe closes at day
24 and in situations when the closure
doesn't happen properly that leads to
problems like
ananal now let's talk about the risk
factors of anany one of the potential
risk factor for anany is the nutritional
defects especially deficiency of folic
acid or vitamin B9 there could be also
other effects like exposure to
environmental toxicant like pesticides
heavy metals Etc obesity and diabetes
increase the risk of this kind of
defects but it is not the sole cause
that lead to an anfy there could be also
genetic predisposition among specific
group of individual which would increase
the chances of having anfy now it's
important to know that within the first
trimester within the first month the
brain development is happening and at
this particular point of time vitamin B9
and vitamin B12 were absolutely
essential and during this period of time
when a pregnant woman even doesn't know
that she is pregnant the brain
development is done so if fet is
deficient it might lead to this kind of
problem that is why all women who is
thinking of getting pregnant should at
least have 400 microgr of folic acid
daily during
pregnancy now the incidence of neural
tube defect especially anany can be
found more in developing countries like
Africa India Etc it is less common in
developed
countries now the question is how does
fet deficiency can lead to this kind of
anany or complete absence of absence of
the brain so fet actually gets converted
to several intermediates that give rise
to nucleotide so folet gets reduced by
tetrahydrofolate reductors to form
tetrah hydrolate eventually 510
methylene tetrahydrofolate is formed
this particular product help in the
conversion from DP to dtmp so obviously
these are the building block of
DNA so just to simplify all this
complicated thing folet is absolutely
essential for nucleotide biosynthesis
and thereby DNA synthesis both purine
and pamine synthesis requires folet so
obviously when folet would be fet would
be required for nucleotide biosynthesis
and nucleotides are required for
processes like DNA replication which is
absolutely essential for a dividing cell
when fet is deficient these nucleotide
biosynthesis is abrogated processes like
DNA replication is abrogated and that is
detri detrimental for a dividing cell
when the brain is developing the cells
are actually stem cells these neuronal
stem cells or neuronal stem cells are
the precursor for the neuron and they
divide they need to divide rapidly in
order to self renew grow the number of
cells and also give rise to neurons so
this process is known as neurogenesis
and this entire process is abrogated
when fet is deficient generally these
radial gal progenitor cells give rise to
one radial Gia and can also give rise to
another newborn
neuron down the timeline it would also
give rise to astrocytes so all these
neurogenic and gly ogenic processes are
abrogated when folet is deficient
because nucleotide synthesis is not good
enough and it is not enough to uh do
cell division in order for a cell to
divide DNA has to be replicated first
enough amount of nucleotide has to be
there in the cell and that is not
possible when fet is deficient that is
why fet deficiency lead to all the uh
neural tube defects and this is the
consequence of fet deficiency and
enil so diagnosis of anfy or any other
neural tube defects can be done using
ultrasound around the week 12 of the
pregnancy also high level of alpha feto
protein is another indicator that there
is something wrong in the neural
development so I hope this video was
useful if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe you can support our
Channel using Super Tank See You in next
video